now the junk has bend the knee to
daenerys and the entire targaryen camp
is heading to winterfell most of the
characters will pretty much be on the
same place at the same time and there
comes the first prediction which is a
reunion between jon and arya we have
been waiting to see a reunion between
those two since the very first season we
have been hoping for their reunion in
season 7 but the two just missed each
other however this meeting most
certainly will take place in the final
season john loves and cares for all his
siblings but john and arya have a unique
bond it was john who secretly had needle
forged for arya encouraging her to
become who she always wanted to be not
the lady that westerosi custom demanded
in fact those two were so close that in
georgia and martin's original outline he
had them remarked as lovers while it's
easy to say that jon will be proud but
also blown away by how much arya has
grown as a fighter it's also safe to say
that ariev will support jon's decision
of banning the knee to the dragon queen
season 7 included many reunions of which
the most notable would be the stark
reunions but none of those would match a
reunion between jon and arya that will
most certainly take place in the very
beginning of the final season upon
arriving at winterfell beside reuniting
with arya john will have our union with
his other siblings and friends john and
sam will see each other for the first
time since jon was killed sammy likely
revealed to jon his true parentage but i
also expect howland reed to finally
appear in the current timeline and
confirm these same statements to jon
with some evidence some also might know
that john was killed and resurrected
since he was sending ravens to him at
winterfell but it has not been shown and
therefore we cannot tell for sure if sam
knows what happened at castle black if
this is something sam will learn once he
reunites with his best friend it's
possible that beside revealing to jon
that he's a targaryen sam might also
proclaim jon azra hai in the season 7
premiere sho pointed out that the book
really picked up and started reading was
a book about the long night while the
exact part she was reading was about the
prophecy of azra hai he is a legendary
figure in the faith of the lord of light
thousands years ago during the long
night azer hai forged the sword
lightbringer which heals to defeat the
darkness of the great other this came
with a price however as in order to
unleash the sword's true powers he had
to plunge it into the heart of his
loving wife a prophecy that was
mentioned multiple times throughout the
series foretells that azrael will be
reborn as the prince that was promised i
already made a video regarding which
character might be this prophesied
savior but john's son of ice and fire
seems more and more to be the lord's
chosen anyways upon finding out about
joshua parentage in season 7 which
basically confirms that he is a song of
ice and fire and upon finding out about
jon's death and resurrection in the
final season it's quite possible that
sam will proclaim jon as rahai a hero
that was reborn amid smoke and salt a
hero that will will the flaming sword to
stand against the others and if he falls
the world falls with him i also believe
that a book about the long night that
gilly was reading in season 7 in
premiere will resurface in the final
season which would likely lead sam to
once again ask branny if he is able to
look back in time but this time even
further into the past to see what
exactly happened the last time the white
walkers came for the living this is how
sam and bran will play a huge role in
the final season as they will help jon
and daenerys strategize for their fight
against the night king and his army of
the dead this will most probably involve
quite a few flashbacks where we would
learn a bit more about the white walkers
and their motivations if jon snow truly
is the prince that was promised it means
that daenerys is probably going to die
and there comes another prediction which
is the death of the dragon queen both
jon and dany are tied to the ezra high
prophecy which includes a historic
legend of a hero sacrificing his love in
order to save the world from the long
night mel sandra told daenerys that she
has a role to play in the prophecy as
does jon snow daenerys role in the long
night is most likely her eventual
sacrifice and death it seems that just
like azra hai who had to draw his sword
into his life's living heart in order to
create lightbringer john will have to do
the same this means that jon snow as the
prince that was promised will defeat the
night king and save estros but it would
also mean that jon as the last targaryen
will become the new ruler of westeros
even though he never wanted to rule let
me also say that this theory most
certainly matches with george rr
martin's announced bittersweet ending
anyways back to the reunions beside with
his sisters and best friend john will
obviously reunite with bran as well it's
been a long time since jon so bran but
bran did see jon in season 4 when he was
traveling north of the wall he saw john
from afar fighting the millionaires to
avenge the lord commander's death bran
is beside holland reed the only living
man that witnessed jon's birth and even
though he has been waiting the whole
season to reveal the truth to jon i
don't think he will be the one to lead
john to believe he's a targaryen whether
it will be bran or sam that will reveal
to john hitchco lineage in my opinion it
will be hovland reed who will confirm
these statements with some hard proof
that would lead jon to believe that he
is in effect a true heir to the iron
throne the night king has brought down
the wall and is marching towards the
winterfell almost all of westeros on the
other hand is also marching towards
winterfell to defend it against the army
of the dead all in all i don't think
house reid will be the only house beside
house lannister not to join the great
war even though it's possible that
instead of holland reed his daughter
mira might lead small forces of her
house north i think it's time for
holland reed to finally appear and play
his role anyways let's take a little
break from reunions with the prediction
that the night king will hit the last
hearth and car hold first
if they breach the wall the first two
castles in their path are last hearth
and car hole
the ambers on the car starks betrayed
the north
this is what john said when he was
addressing the northern lords in the
season 7 premiere which will on the
other hand likely come true in the
season 8 premiere those castles of house
summer and house skarstark will probably
follow along with their rulers nedanbur
and ellis karstark another prediction
that is highly possible to come true is
jon snow riding rhaegal in the final
season the dragon named after his father
after the heartbreaking battle beyond
the voldeners only has two dragons left
and since she rides jogging it would fit
for jon the other last living targaryen
to ride rhaegal into battle at some
point probably after he learns of his
true parentage a few months ago i made a
video regarding the three-headed dragon
theory that already proved to be quite
accurate so basically in that theory
regular targaryen statement in
daenerys's vision the dragon has three
heads means that each of the nearest
three dragons will have their own
writers for all of you that are not
caught up with the books and they're
probably wondering when did regards say
this let me explain it to you in a few
sentences then there are so visions in
the house of the undying in both in the
books and on the show but her visions
are quite different in the books
daenerys saw no vision of drogo and
their son but she did see many other
visions of which one was the vision of
her brother reagar saying the dragon has
three heads in that video i also
explained how the theory has been
foreshadowed as well as which characters
might make up the three-headed dragon
prophecy long story short who those
three dragon riders might be i said that
daenerys obviously has an unbreakable
bond with dragon and jon snow being the
last targaryen beside dany would ride
the dragon named after his father but
not before the last season regarding the
third dragon rider that is required to
fulfill the three-headed dragon theory i
stated that it would be nice to see
daenerys john and tyrion riding the
dragons into the battle against the
night king but i also said it was kind
of too obvious and simple to be true at
least too obvious for game of thrones
instead of tirion who seemed to have
developed connections with danish dragon
i stated that the night king will be the
third dragon rider and therefore we
would have daenerys fire the night king
ice and jon snow ice and fire riding
three dragons whether it's jon or
someone else like bran or even tyrion i
do think that rhaegal will have his
rider in the last episodes of game of
thrones the last prediction that will
surely come true is arguably the most
interesting reunion of the final season
or even of the entire series so far it's
a reunion between baron stark and jaime
lannister as we all know back in the
first season jaime was caught having an
intimate relationship by bran to keep
bran from reporting what he just saw
which would have resulted with jamie
cersei and older children being executed
jaime pushed bran out of the tower
window casting brand the ability to walk
and rendering him a [ __ ] anyways
jamie's heading north to support the
living side and he will eventually
reunite with bran and winterfell the
only question regarding this reunion is
how will bran react at first glance we
would assume that bran will react
angrily since that's the man who almost
killed him the last time they saw each
other but that most likely will not be
the case in the fourth episode of the
seventh season brent stark stated that
he is not bran stark anymore but rather
the three-eyed raven meaning that bran
will not sentence jaime to death nor
will he allow jon or daenerys to do the
same bran will likely be the one to
reveal the whole truth behind jaime's
so-called betrayal over daenerys's
father the mad king jaime was one of the
established members of the kingsguard
under the mad king and his duty was to
protect the king from harm at all times
but even if jaime decided not to kill
the mad king but rather to let him kill
hundreds of thousands of innocent people
he would have still broken and under
oath
you have forsaken every vow you ever
took so many vows
they make you swear and swear
defend the king obey the king obey your
father protect the innocent defend the
weak
and what if your father despises the
king
what if the king
massacres the innocent
it's too much
no matter what you do you're forsaking
one power or another
the kingsguard is an elite group of
seven knights who are religiously
influenced by a code of chivalry and
honor this code states that the knights
must defend the weak and innocent so
even if jaime did let the mad king to
burn the capital to the ground along
with all innocent people with it jaime
would have still broken an oath in my
opinion rather than sentencing jaime to
death bran will reveal to everyone the
real truth behind jaime's so-called
betrayal resulting with jaime becoming a
hero that he actually has been his whole
life there are so many predictions and
theories that i have in my mind for the
final season so make sure to stay tuned
for the upcoming videos